so the key here again is spacing I need
you in the corner and if your man so
much as looks my way then I'm gonna get
it to you then I go for three yes but is
merely a pump fake no I pull the ball
down I step over the line and I whack
down the big four contested fadeaway -
from the elbow no that's exactly what
you shouldn't do Chris you know I can
hit that shot over anybody although it's
not about hitting shots about hitting
efficient shots not you too with this
efficiency fad whatever happened to the
days when Knights would go one-on-one
mano a mano in the paint in a slow
grinding duel no no if you want a role
here in house Rockets you must
understand the system study the
analytics study plenty come on oh please
I remember when you used to be fun
whatever happened to Banana Boat Chris
he learned how to win and he wants to
teach his friends so they could win
together I want to win it's just it's
all so boring these days analytics
efficiency defense hmm you know what
come with me I want to show you
something
whoa
[Music]
ah Camaro welcome to the Johnson spacing
Center here are maesters tests the
frontiers of knowledge to give house
rockets a competitive edge what's that
why that's our namesake the rocket we
value long-range weaponry here house
rockets has never shied away from
experimentation some produce incredible
results and others not so much
what is this for that was the AL Ming's
chamber pad
Oh mellow have a look at this
what is that those are moons orbiting
another world makes you think you might
not be the center of the universe after
all huh so you're saying I'm just
another planet no he's saying you are a
moons James Harden is the planet
well actually Chris I am a star and
stars should be starters mellow just
needs a headband I'm gonna put a hoodie
here mellow you're not getting no I bet
the only reason I'm not starting is
because D'Antoni's still bitter about
New York and now now he's just working
off the model the model it's not
possible
I can't just suit 33s again look right
here James if the model is correct you
could triple your offense and pull us
out of this slump but what if I miss
them I could go over 27 myself ah
but James what if you make them
how what Camello what are you doing here
Carmelo's interested in the model really
analytics Melo this is the model we feed
her data and she gives us answers
untainted by human bias huh why to shift
six arms and full booth what's designed
by a bunch of nerds who let's just say
haven't had too much experience with the
anatomy of a female Camillo you have to
understand this machine it doesn't care
about your feelings the model only knows
pure analytics if this thing truly knows
basketball then I should have nothing to
fear show me how it works these are your
career stats let's speed them in okay
life's empty calories
[Music]
okay model should circle mellow be in
the Hall of Fame ah look at that first
ballot yeah brilliant now I want to know
what my role here should be mayor oh
sure take it away model what should be
my role on house rockets
you should have dunked that the other
Lane
this model is nothing but a hater how is
this bloody thing even work don't
comment that's where the computers are
computers what's a computer hello Jenna
oh the computers do all the calculations
needed to run the model oh do they will
do any of you even watch basketball what
what is there lice these poor souls
witnessed the dark ages of basketball in
the early aughts the endless post plays
the long twos sir Jordan on the Wizards
after a second Finals appearance by
House Nets they couldn't bear it any
longer to gouge out their eyes but on a
positive note it turns out they're
perfect for doing double blinded
analytics many became computers the rest
became referees all right well we really
should get going though you're beginning
to taint their judgment this is madness
well if you settle your emotional
response you'd see it's all quite
logical really no no this is all wrong
your cold heartless numbers know nothing
of my value anyone with eyes can see the
beauty of my game a ten-time all-star
behind PJ Tucker really marquise Chris
well I refuse to accept it and I'll
never accept it why did you even bring
me here
because you're worth the risk another
veteran minimum Carmello Lord Morey has
given you a chance and it may be the
only one you have left well that's
ridiculous I just need the ball I can
still take any night one-on-one just
give me the rocket all huh Oh what come
on II mean New York
[Music]
[Music]
interesting
seven hells Austin Rivers wake up God
got it
Norman what do you do results only a new
gamer sounds why didn't anyone tell me
what you just got or subscribing that
they notify you so why are you watching
it